[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUZANNE: Hello all, and welcome
to this deep dive on Play data.
Have you ever been
in a situation
where you released an app,
and realized only days later
that you had to replace it?
Do you appreciate that the
console has great acquisition
reports for in app
purchases, but doesn't
offer a lot of insight
for other business models?
And have you ever wanted to take
a deep dive into your own data,
but felt that our statistic
pages were not powerful enough?
If you're thinking
yes to any of these,
we have some great
news to share.
We recognize that
every business,
and every role
within the business,
may have different data needs.
And we want to make our
data work for all of you.
In this talk, you
will learn what
we've done to help you monitor
your production releases,
explore new ways to
dig into your own data,
and gain new business insights.
My name is Suzanne, I'm a
product manager on Play,
and I'll be talking you through
the new release dashboard
that we launched yesterday.
But first, a few introductions.
TAMZIN TAYLOR: Hi there,
my name is Tamzin Taylor.
I work for Google Play
business development in AMEA.
DARIO FRENI: Hi, I'm Dario,
I'm one of the engineering
leads on the Play console.
I focus on making our analytics
metric timely and useful
to our developers.
SUZANNE: So, let's start
with your app releases,
and how we're helping
you ensure that you
don't leave a bad
release in production
any longer than needed.
With our new low latency metrics
and release specific break down
into your data, we're giving
you an hour-by-hour view
into your app release
health, out of the box,
without a need for an SDK.
This will allow you
to make decisions
about the roll out
of your release
sooner, and with
more confidence.
We've always been ahead
of the curve with tools
to prepare great releases.
We have the
pre-launch report, we
have the alpha and
the beta channels,
but we haven't yet given you the
data to monitor your production
release as it happens.
We now give you a
product that allows
you to look at the core
release metrics in one
view, the release dashboard.
Within a couple of
hours of your release
entering the
production track, you
will see data for that
release on the dashboard.
So, when you push a new
release, you obviously
care about crashes.
The crashes that we
used to show were
those where a user
proactively reported a crash.
But we also now have
device reported crashes,
and that's the metric
that you see here.
Unless a user opted out during
the set up of their device,
all crashes are
reported automatically,
which should mean a
lot more data for you.
The other metric you
should really care about
is ANRs, application
not responding.
These are events where
the Android operating
system reports that your app
becomes unresponsive for five
seconds or more.
Now, if on the crash card
you click on View Clusters,
or on the ANR card you
click on View ANRs,
you'll be able to see if
your release introduced
any new crashes or ANRs
you should care about.
And you can explore
the new crash
and ANR metrics there as well.
So to learn more about the
new crash and ANR metrics,
and to learn exactly 10 secrets
about health metrics, please
come back to this
same stage at 5:30
PM today to see Fergus,
Riccardo, and Joe talk.
Now, back to the
release dashboard.
So, I showed you
crashes and ANRs.
Releases aren't all
about app health, though.
You also want to see ratings and
reviews specific to your latest
version.
When the average rating
for your current release
is well below that of
your overall rating,
you may want to start looking
into your one and two star
reviews to see
what's going wrong,
and possibly even move on
to halting your release.
But what if you could also
see low latency install
and uninstall events that
are specific to your release?
And what if you could
know how many uninstalls
came from updated devices?
Are you losing
existing customers
because your new
version doesn't perform?
Installs broken down by
new installs and updates
can tell a powerful
story too, though.
Have enough users
updated it for me
to push my stage rollouts
to the next stage?
As I've started hinting, it's
not all about a single metric.
Your crash tool may warn
you if you get a huge spike,
your PM may tell you if
your ratings suddenly drop.
But what about subtle
but significant changes
across the board?
Would you ever notice
if you didn't see them
all in the same place?
Maybe your crashes
go up, but not
to a point where you would
halt your release just yet.
But your ratings are down,
and if you look further,
your uninstalls are starting
to trend above average.
The combined data may tell you
that this is not early stage
noise, but actually
a real problem
that you need to investigate.
So the context provided
by this holistic view
is precisely how Play data will
help you make decisions sooner,
and with more confidence.
So far, you've seen
a bunch of metrics
that tell you a lot about
your production release.
Both are looked
at in isolation--
what are my ratings doing?
And together-- So, what are my
ANRs doing to my uninstalls,
or to my ratings?
I've kept one of the
most powerful features
from you, though, and
that's comparison.
During user studies we ran
for the release dashboard,
we noticed that virtually
every participant mentioned
that the success of a
release is measured relative
to the success of
a previous release.
Everybody has their
own idea of what's
an acceptable number of crashes
and an acceptable rating.
So release dashboards, when
you open it later today,
has a selector at
the top that allows
you to pick a past
release to compare
your current release against.
So, here's what comparison would
look like for uninstall events
and for crashes.
The power of
comparing is that it
gives you even more signals
to increase your confidence.
You don't only
have your crashes,
you don't only have the impact
that your ANRs are having
on your ratings,
but you can also
see how these metrics compare
against a previous successful
release.
And Jam City, developer of big
hits like Panda Pop, Cookie
Jam, and Genies and Gems,
confirms exactly those notions.
Quicker insight into
success or problems,
and comparing crash
and ANR metrics
against the previous
release to see
if they need to start looking
into newly introduced crashes.
And Wish, a very
popular shopping app,
say that they can now ramp
up their releases faster
and with more
confidence, and respond
to issues more intelligently.
The head of product
also specifically
mentions that comparing
ratings across releases
gave very important
qualitative feedback, which
ties back to what I mentioned
before about not focusing
on app health alone.
Right, that's a release
dashboard that makes Play data
work for you in low latency.
So, go look for it in the
Play console when you next
push a new version out.
It is the new top most item
under release management.
You'll be confident
sooner, and you'll
have fewer users spending time
looking at a bad app release
version.
TAMZIN TAYLOR:
Thank you, Suzanne.
So when we think about the
app development lifecycle,
clearly the release
is a critical point.
I don't think anyone disagrees.
But, once you have
your app in production
and you're happy
with it, you probably
want to drive lots of new
and valuable installs, right?
Now, given that you've all
heard about the new release
dashboard, I have
confidence when
you leave I/O you'll
be able to have
a great release of your app.
And once you have
your app live, what
are the four questions you
should be asking yourself
to grow your business?
You should be asking, which
marketing channels are
driving my most valuable users?
Which countries are
they coming from?
Are my install and buy
conversion rates actually good?
And which channels are bringing
me my most loyal users?
So why is this important, and
what am I going to tell you?
Well, I'll get onto
that in a second.
So in my role, I talk to
developers every single day--
probably some of
you in the audience
who I speak to regularly.
And what I hear
you say is that you
need to know how effective
your marketing channels are
for attracting and retaining
new valuable users.
I hear you say that
you need more data
to make the right decision on
where you spend your money,
and where you spend your
time and effort to optimize
your growth strategies.
Now, you may already know
this, but, in case you
don't, a couple of years ago we
launched the user acquisition
report.
To remind you, the
user acquisition report
shows you how many
people are going
to your place or
listing page; of those,
how many people
install your app;
and of those, how many
people buy, and buy again.
You can cut this report by five
main channels: the Play Store,
Google AdWords, Google
Search, third party referrers,
and track channels.
Now, since last I/O we've
launched two improvements
to this report just to make
it more useful for you,
and help you with your
growth strategies.
But first, I want to
touch on track channels,
and why you should really
be using these today.
So one of the most powerful
features of the user
acquisition report
is the ability
to track and see acquisition
broken down by UTM tag.
Now, UTM tag lets
you identify a link
you've used to drive traffic
to your Store listing page.
Any link can use UTM tags.
Your social shares, your
web sites, even other apps.
And by tagging
these links you can
see all of your traffic broken
down by a unique identifier.
Why is this important?
Well, if you're going to
spend money on a campaign,
you probably want to
know how it's performing.
And this allows
you to see exactly
which link is contributing
to your most valuable users.
It's really powerful.
You can apply this
link to anything
you create to track
the contribution
that that specific link has
had to your growth success.
So UTM tags are great
for planned campaigns,
but when I speak to
developers a lot of them
tell me that majority
of the traffic
actually comes organically
through the Play Store.
I can see some nodding.
Now, you may remember I told
you we'd made two improvements
to the user acquisition report.
So the first one is we've added
country breakdown to the user
acquisition traffic report.
And this is really
helpful because,
as you may have
heard earlier today,
or yesterday, we now have two
billion Android active devices
across the world.
So, this report
helps you identify
where your unrealized
opportunity is
for international
expansion and domination.
Now, let me share with you a
case study of a partner who's
used this to their benefit.
Concrete Software
is a Minneapolis
based games company.
Perhaps, like you in the
audience or on the live stream,
they run a really
lean operation--
they've got about 30 people.
So getting the right
information about their business
quickly so they can act
on it is pretty crucial.
About a year ago,
Concrete Software
were using the user
acquisition reports
for their game Arctic Cat, which
is a snowmobile game, obviously
set in a snowy landscape.
And they could see that
their install conversion
was a little bit lower
than what they'd expected.
When we launched
country breakdown,
instantly they could see
why this was the case.
What they saw was that countries
in cold climates with snow
had a five times greater
install conversion
than warmer climates
that did not have snow,
such as Brazil,
Indonesia, et cetera.
So suddenly they realize
they should be concentrating
their optimization on these
cold climate countries, which
you can see that they've
done by increasing
their install 25%
for these countries
by using store
listings experiments.
So now they know where
to target their spend
to get the best
return on investment.
So, one thing you've told us--
and I heard this quite
a lot from partners--
was that while you think the
user acquisition report is
great for understanding your
business, I kept getting asked,
but is this actually good?
How much opportunity exists
to drive my acquisition
even further?
So late last year we
launched peer benchmarks.
Peer benchmarks help you
see how your app compares
to similar apps in the
same category who use
the same monetization model.
So these peer benchmarks can
be seen in the user acquisition
channel, and in the
country breakdown channel.
And this is really
helpful for three reasons.
Number one, it shows
you exactly where
you need to focus
your improvement
efforts for your conversion.
Secondly, it can show you where
you can make the business case
to invest more in acquisition.
And thirdly, it can show
you where you can simply
celebrate your team's success.
So let me share with you a
couple of partners who use
this data for their advantage.
Now, you may be
familiar with Viber.
They're a communications
app, and they operate
in a pretty competitive market.
So it's really important
that they use all the labors
at their disposal to increase
the top of the funnel,
and get more users
to install their app.
Once we launched
peer benchmarks,
Viber could finally
see what good is.
And they knew what goals
to set themselves to reach
for their in-store conversion.
Using this report, Viber were
able to identify countries that
were below the peer benchmark.
One such example was
the UK and the US.
Similarly, they seemed like
sister countries, right?
They both speak English.
But as Viber discovered,
in fact, user behavior
was quite different,
and they saw
that the UK install
conversion was
much lower than the peer set.
This immediately allowed
them to jump on the problem,
and resolve it using store
listening experiments,
testing the image logo,
descriptions, to bring it
back up to par.
Now, I'm sure you're all
familiar with the Star Wars
franchise, and you may also
be familiar with the EA game
Galaxy Heroes which
launched a while ago.
What they noticed
was that there were
lots of people coming to
their page store listing,
but not as many were installing
the app as they expected.
Once we launched
peer benchmarking,
EA were able to see that,
actually the problem was not
the game, but that the
category that the game sat in
had a lower conversion
than other categories
in which EA has games.
And this led them
to think, if they
could change the perception
and the display of the game,
could they increase conversion?
So peer benchmarking
gave EA the ability
to think not only in terms of
category, but also country.
And has prompted them to
pivot the position in the game
to increase conversion.
It's had a profound
impact on the way
that they approach top
of funnel marketing.
With this, they're
able to create
unique assets for
different categories
and different countries
to increase conversion.
So, if you're a games company
or you use in-app purchase,
you might be thinking--
this is fantastic.
I'm going to go home,
and dive into my data,
and find ways I can improve.
But how many of you
here in the audience--
and you can put your
hand up if you're also
watching the live stream--
have a subscription
model, or an ad
funded model, or an
e-commerce model?
Fantastic, so there's
quite a few of you.
Version one of the
user acquisition report
was really useful for
everyone, but perhaps
geared more towards developers
with in-app purchase model.
But, like you here in the room
today, the majority of you
put your hand up, we know there
are other really successful
business models
where you really care
about building long-term
user relationships, right?
So today, I'm very
excited to announce
the launch of version
2 of the funnel, which
has been built specifically
with businesses like yours
in mind, who care
about user retention.
The first report shows
retention periods,
which is a critical
metric for understanding
which channels are bringing
in your most loyal users.
These retained
installers are people
who have your app installed on
at least one of their devices.
This is your retained
install base.
So this-- and you can see the
percentages-- will show you
what the opportunity is
to increase your user
retention using techniques
like notifications, e-mail,
or just increasing your quality.
Better yet, one of my
favorites, is the ability
to export this data via CSV.
So now you'll be able to
extract your retained user--
I can see people
clapping, it's great.
You'll be able to extract your
retained user, your install
and buy conversion, and
your peer benchmarks,
to help you manage your
business better and look
for ways to improve.
Now, I work a lot with
subscription partners
from the news industry
through to health and fitness,
and they are always
asking me for more data.
And since subscriptions are a
growing and important business
model, I'm really
happy to let you
know that we've built a report
specifically for your business.
Now, as much as I
would like to, I'm
not going to ruin the surprise.
If you'd like to learn more
about the subscription report,
come back here 10:30
AM tomorrow morning
to hear more about that.
So in summary, I know from
today you're going to go away,
and you'll look at
your app, and you'll
be able to see which
channels are driving
your most valuable users, which
countries they're coming from.
And you'll be able
to say, where are
the opportunities to increase
my install and buy conversion,
and how can I increase
my user retention?
All of these reports are here
to help you optimize your growth
strategies.
Not just for installs, but for
long term value and business
success.
Regardless of the
way you monetize,
we believe the acquisition
reports are there for you
to help grow your business.
DARIO FRENI: Thanks, Tamzin.
So, in addition to
the release dashboard
and the user acquisition report,
which give you unique insights
into your data, as you
know, in the Play console
we also have more
specialized dashboard
for specific use cases like
crashes, or Android vitals,
or revenue, and so on.
But we understand that not
all businesses are alike,
and each of you might care
about different metrics,
and might care about
doing analysis in ways
that we can not predict.
So we know many of you know
use our statistics page.
But, we also know
that sometimes,
for certain analysis, you have
to download the CSV export
and then craft your own
analysis using spreadsheets
or other external tool.
And we understand why.
How, for example, could you
understand whether W last year
Black Friday sales went
better or worse than this year
Black Friday sales, right?
Or how could you compare,
or find correlations,
between two different metrics
such as ratings and crashes?
So, if I take a step back and
think about our old statistics
page, there were a number
of issues you raised and you
asked us to fix.
It was sometimes slow
to load, the date
ranges you could
pick were inflexible,
there was no possibility of
selecting multiple metrics,
and also, and this was
an important point,
the latency of the
visibility of the data
was often insufficient.
So we listened to your
feedback, and we brought it
into our product with a bunch of
the launches we had yesterday.
It begins with the
new statistics page,
and I would like to
introduce this to you today.
So here is how it looks.
At the first glance, you
can see that the interface
is much nicer and more
polished than before.
It has been designed from the
ground up from our material
design specifications.
With this launch, we are also
including some new metrics
in the statistics page,
such as, for example,
the revenue metrics.
And also the install,
update, and uninstall
events, which are also available
on the release dashboard
that Suzanne present before.
Let me walk you through some
exciting features of this page.
First, you can now
choose any date range you
want to visualize your data.
A nice date picker is
available on the top right
corner of the page.
There are some
pre-selected time ranges,
but you can also pick a custom
one you want to visualize.
Previously, we only had three,
if I remember correctly,
date ranges fixed that
always ended at today.
By being able to
choose any date ranges,
you can do some analysis
such as look at Q4 of 2016,
or January of last year.
In addition, when you
select the date range,
the new statistics
page, by default,
will also overlay a
comparison of that date range
with its most recent history.
So for example, if you
pick the previous week
of the last week of
data, you will also
see data relative to the
previous week overlaid
on the chart as a dotted line.
If you hover that on the
chart, a useful tool tip
will give you more data
about specific data points,
such as the exact
date, but also,
how they compare numerically.
So this feature
will allow you to do
one of the comparisons
that was mentioned before.
For example, you could
compare last year Black Friday
sales to this year very easily.
So our partners at Expedia told
us that they love this feature.
They were actually able to do
very quickly, and at a glance,
year-over-year or
quarter-over-quarter comparison
analysis real quick.
And they said that there
is no other app analytics
tool that they know of that does
this so easily and seamlessly.
Another cool feature
is the ability
of compare to different metric.
If you configure your report by
clicking the Configure Report
button, you can now select
an additional metric
to compare it to, so that you
can spot correlation, or lack
of correlation, between
different metrics
such as installer and revenue,
or as you can see here, crashes
and ratings.
On the chart, the
two different metrics
would be plotted with
two different colors.
And as you can see, the
date range comparison
will still be available,
and the tool tip
will include information about
both metric and different date
ranges.
So this feature will
allow you to spot quickly
correlation, or
lack of correlation,
between different metrics.
We've spoken to Move,
Inc. That had early access
to the statistics page for
their apartment and home rental
search app.
They were able to spot
correlation between crashes
and uninstall, effectively
showing the impact of app
quality on the audience.
So now, think about this.
Maybe many of you have
a hard time prioritizing
fix and technical depth over
building new features, right?
But once you have
this data in hand,
you can now build a
case to work on that.
So, this is how you
can use this data.
Next, for some of our
metrics available,
such as install, update,
and uninstall still event,
you can now select to see
hourly data instead of daily
when visualizing these.
Now, reducing the
latency of our metrics
has been one of your
loudest concerns,
and we've taken that
really seriously.
We've worked really
hard on that.
And I'm happy to announce
that for the metrics that
are available hourly, you
should expect them to be
updated within a few hours.
In fact, if you log on
the Play console right
now, for this metric
you should already
see data for this morning.
The hourly data will allow you
to observe hour-by-hour trends,
and also to do
analysis that were
more difficult to do before.
For example, in case
of offline events,
like a TV ad, and
understanding how
this affects your installed
metric, for example.
As you can see here,
the comparison feature
are still available
also when you
look at the data at
an hourly granularity.
Last, but not least,
if you remember,
the previous stats
page used to show you
the top 10 results for
certain breakdowns,
such as countries and device.
If you wanted to
dig deeper into data
you had to download the CSV
export and observe those.
Well, we improved the
situation significantly
in the new statistics page.
You still have the
top 10 results,
but you can now search
for any breakdown.
And as you can see,
the table will also
show a numerical comparison
between different metrics
if you have selected so.
And in addition, you can select
specific breakdowns, up to 2,
and see them plotted
on the chart.
And again, as before,
all the comparison
features I described
before are still available.
So, you can do comparison
between multiple metrics,
between multiple date ranges,
at an hourly granularity,
for specific breakdowns.
So Jakob, the CEO of Play
Lab, who should be in the room
today--
OK.
So they are game developer
company from Thailand.
And he told us that
he loved to have
the possibility of comparing
multiple metrics at a glance,
and without going
through a spreadsheet,
and also seeing per device
or per country comparison.
So the new stats
page allows you to do
more sophisticated analysis
much more quickly than before.
So to summarize, the
new statistics page
is a powerful and versatile
tool to analyze data,
and to achieve quickly what
you could only achieve before
by downloading the data and
using our external tools or ad
hoc analysis.
We are publishing new
metrics, such as revenue,
and install, update,
and uninstalled events.
Some of these metrics
will be available hourly,
and for these metrics
you should also
expect a much lower
latency than before.
So I hope you will enjoy
using these features
for your business as much as
we enjoy building them for you.
Thank you, and back to Suzanne.
[APPLAUSE]
SUZANNE: Well, thank
you for taking us
through the new
statistics page, Dario,
and for the business reporting
walk through, Tamzin.
So I'd like to wrap up
with some final words.
We were very pleased to announce
all these features here today.
With the release
dashboard, we give you
feasibility into the
health of your release.
With the acquisition
reports, you
can see how efficient your
marketing channels are
for additional business models.
And finally, with the
new statistics pages
we're giving you a
much more flexible way
to look at your own data.
Together, these
features make Play data
work even harder
for you and help you
build successful apps on Play.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]